[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 190 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Asha and I'm here with my colleague
John hey John how's it going pretty good
so what do we have in store this week so
this week we get to sit down with Cheryl
Chen to talk about ml and AI and what it
means to her and really really amazing
ml and AI trends that sounds awesome and
if I remember from the notes correctly
we've got a question of the week about
one of my personal passions Ruby
but first let's spend some time on cool
thing of the week
[Applause]
what do you have for us this week John
there are new AMD processors coming to
Google and Google Cloud and there are a
lot of general-purpose workloads that
will see a pretty good performance
improvement around the same price point
you're gonna have a higher base
frequency which is really great
better compute workloads for a memory
bandwidth and they're gonna be roughly
around a 60% platform memory bin with
increase which is kind of amazing that
sounds super cool so one of my cool
things for the week is that Sarah
Robinson on our team turned me on to
this Cagle dataset that pulls data from
Petfinder the adoption website and I
don't know what she's doing with it but
I found the dataset and I thought it was
super cool and looks like there's a
Keiko competition around predicting how
long pets are gonna stay in the shelter
if I remember reading it correctly but
it has pictures of adorable animals that
were looking for homes at some point in
the last couple years so that's awesome
because adorable animals are always
awesome so that is my cool thing of the
week number one awesome I'm pretty sure
everybody's happy to see cute animals
and I know Sarah's been really really
having a lot of fun with that dataset
that's awesome so do you have any more
cool things for us this week John yes so
one thing is now you can stream data
from cloud storage into bigquery using
cloud functions and this is really
amazing because you get really high
availability in auto-scaling
and this creates almost real-time access
to your data using cloud storage which
is really amazing because you get your
information faster and respond more
quickly to events because of cloud
functions so it's kind of cool
yeah code functions I was a big skeptic
on functions as a service for quite a
while but I have definitely come to see
the value and how useful it is so that's
awesome and do you have anything else
for the cool things of the week yeah
actually one more thing and this is
again hitting my passion project your
Ruby we now have App Engine standard for
Ruby I believe by the time this episode
goes out it will be GA but it might
still be beta where we're still trying
to sort out when the GA date will be but
App Engine standard we've had App Engine
flex for a while App Engine standard
gives us faster deploy times and it
gives a scale to zero and a bunch of
other stuff I couldn't have a blog post
on my blog AGGA miser com coming out
later this week hope
we may be early next week talking about
how to use it but this is a huge huge
thing for my ruby friends that they can
try something on GCP that really works
and handles a lot of the hosting and
stuff for you I've tested it out with an
app I have that involves file uploads
cloud storage users cloud sequel and it
works really really well out of the box
as long as you understand a couple of
the kind of weirdnesses will go with
weirdnesses about using GCP and I'll get
to one of those later in the question of
the week but I think it's time to go
talk to Cheryl now sounds good let's
hear what Cheryl has to say about
machine learning and AI
[Music]
it's also and I'm here with John today
and our guest today is Cheryl hey Cheryl
can you introduce yourself hey everybody
I'm Cheryl I work at Google with all of
you that's all so so can you tell us
what you do at Google yeah so I'm an
advocate I work in machine learning
specifically I'm working on awesome
product called Auto ml tables and what
it really does is it takes the concept
of machine learning and really breaks it
down to what data you have and what kind
of predictions you want to make and
these are just really interesting tools
that keep emerging it seems like month
after month so I've been in machine
learning and AI for quite some time and
served on a bunch of different teams and
roles in my time at Google that's
awesome and you've done some really
really interesting things like I see
that you've taught a class so you want
to talk about that a little bit and more
about your background a little bit yeah
so I would say that you know I was born
on a cold winter night or something like
that
I think a really defining moment for me
was when I first started playing video
games and I had this hero's journey
experience that really got me through
the ups and downs of life and led me
into pursuing technology like it really
started curiosity in me as to like how
do we utilize these tools and so my
background really took off I think in
undergrad where you were kind of around
all of these professors and researchers
and I took a particular interest in
artificial intelligence specifically
because I felt like games had improved
so much in graphics but not so much in
the logic behind the game and then I
went on and did my PhD with leading
expert in AI for storytelling Michel
Matias and from there I thought I would
be in academia for a good chunk of my
life and I did a lot of teaching in the
midst of going through grad school but
then I also had an opportunity to work
at Google as a software engineer and saw
like kind of a whole new world opened up
and decided to come to Google and I
ended up in the you know right place at
the right time like I was at Google
brain when sundar announced that we were
going a I first when I was at Stanford
teaching
it was a time when a lot of people were
interested in AI so I was putting
together the curriculum that was gonna
get used around the world it just is
something that I've always thought like
an affinity for wow that is super cool
did I hear right you got partly got into
AI because you thought that NPCs in
video games should be smarter yes
absolutely
if you just looked at like Final Fantasy
one and then like Final Fantasy 15 you'd
see this like huge difference in the
feel and the environment and the sound
and scene but when you interact like I
just remembered I think for me it was
Final Fantasy 10 and you would look at
the maps of the world and it's like a
tube you're just going down a pipe of
like point to point to point to point I
mean on your way there you're it's like
it fantastical and amazing but what
about the actual universe itself you
know awesome I think a lot of our
listeners probably know about AI and
have a good idea but it is but a lot of
people to find it differently so like
what do you consider AI Cheryl so we can
all be working from the same set of
definitions stay that is definitely a
question that comes up a lot I've been
interested in studying and working AI
for the last like 10 years so I've seen
the kind of shift in how people think
about AI I would say that it really
stems from the 50s and 60s that
definition is the one that I feel like
is historical and has meaning and there
was a you know that Dartmouth summer
school where the term a I was even
coined I think that there's definitely
historical meaning that I think is
valuable to consider I also feel like
Alan Turing's paper he wrote in the
early 50s about chem machine stink was
also posing these really important
thought experiments as to what were what
what do we mean when we say intelligence
now I think when I've taught you know
whether it's like an 11 year old or like
a grad student yeah the real question
that you can really relate anybody to is
you know what does it mean to be human
or a more specific question as you know
what are things that machines do better
than humans and one of the things that
humans do better than machines and that
has always been kind of like a standard
of how we develop and measure artificial
intelligence so then when you think
about things that humans do we can see
smell hear think we have language
creative or visual all of these things
being captured by technology kind of
creates these different areas of
research where they were talking
robotics or natural language or machine
learning and machine learning is really
kind of taken center stage in the last
couple years I think it's really the
move that made sundar announced that we
were going AI first because of all the
advancements that we were able to do and
that happened as a result of all of the
increased ability to compute the amount
of data that we had and just the
algorithms working better so AI has
historical meaningfulness it also has
different meaning depending on the
context that you're looking at for me
like my interest rate I was
believability in expressivity so how we
use AI to extend humans ability to
communicate and express themselves and
story and I think machine learning and
deep learning has been in the last
couple years the big emphasis of what
has shown to be more effective than ever
had been before so if you're talking
about AI I think it's worth reading the
history and understanding where it comes
from I think it's really important to
not just think AI as being something
really cool but really understand the
problems that AI is trying to solve in
which case you'll get a different angle
of what AI is and finally if you're
thinking about AI and what the buzz is
about today it's about deep learning and
machine learning because of the efficacy
of these new advancements and technology
so I think I know the answer to this but
I'm not confident so can you tell me
what deep learning is yes so machine
learning is something you know Alan
Turing back in the 1950s he said machine
learning you know can machines think can
machines actually acquire knowledge on
their own that's some of the earliest
published concepts around machine
learning I think one of the earliest
programs that was actually made was
actually a lot of these early AI
programmers were like psychologists or
like they were in like these
interdisciplinary roles of Technology
and psychology and I believe that the
first machine learning program was
actually a checkers program where
somebody was wondering how could I build
a checkers program that could beat me at
checkers and so it would apply some sort
of reinforcement learning to be able to
figure out how to win at checkers
that actually happened not that much
living must have been like a decade
later or something for which that
happened so it wasn't some
that was like in our recent last you
know five to ten years now the problem
is is that there's been a lot of like
randomness and in predictability of
having the Machine just kind of process
information on its own without the
guidance and the formalities that we lay
out like the rule of a systems that we
typically use that I think hand-in-hand
like there's an intuition of like oh we
can kind of guide the logic of how the
machine's gonna break down what's the
best decision given a particular
situation like there's all these
different states and this clearly is the
more ideal state and kind of feed all
the information for that
so that's machine learning and again not
everybody agrees this is the way it
works but you know there's AI and then
within AI a part of intelligence is the
ability to learn for which you know
machine learning is just the computer
acquiring its own understanding of some
sort of process or decision so with deep
learning and machine learning there was
this concept of neural networks neural
networks are not the only way this idea
of like a computational neuron is not
the only way machines can learn right
there's other ways decision tree
learning for example but with neural
networks you're basically balancing a
bunch of weights you're given like
information and it goes through these
mathematical calculations in neurons
that balance a bunch of weights to
create this model or this mathematical
representation of how given input a you
get output B how it gets deep is that
it's very limited if you stick to kind
of these purely arithmetic or linear
operations deep learning really
introduces the ability for the computer
to remove and hide some of that
information and pick and choose what
it's going to do and it introduces like
even bigger layer of obscurity but it
gives the Machine more power what it
does come at the cost of is
understandability of what's actually
happening when it makes that decision
there's AI there's machine learning and
then there's deep learning and then
within that is a neural networks and
then the hidden layers are the ones that
make it a deep learning system awesome
you saw something really interesting
that I wanted to ask about you mentioned
that early on a I was pretty much
psychiatrist and someone in computer
science like the intermediary track but
I'm curious for AI nmo like where's that
line drawn between
what decisions a human makes and you
know the type of models that you have
that actually build and what the Machine
actually does yeah I think that humans
are imperfect so when I ask the question
in a classroom what are things like
humans do better than machines or the
things that machines do better than
humans and then like a common debate
right is driving so who's gonna be a
better driver or what is gonna be a
better driver is it gonna be the human
or is it gonna be the computer and
you're kind of torn a lot of things that
humans can do that we take for granted
but they're also just clear weaknesses
that we have right like when we're tired
and we're inebriated there's like
different things that prevent us from
functioning at full capacity and so a
lot of you know our traffic laws are
built around this idea that you have all
your like correct sensory functions in
order when we think about how we create
policies for traffic laws for example
like they exist that you need to be able
to see for example to be able to drive a
car but there is like some margin of
like well you don't have to have exact
perfect immaculate like 20/20 vision you
can have you know a little bit less than
that let's say and then there's some
amount less than that and all of that
needs to be researched and considered to
be able to protect the safety of society
as a whole but I don't think that's an
easy question to answer because when I
talk about self-driving cars if we talk
about it in like Silicon Valley over the
Bay Area we're thinking like you know
highway to a tear it's like you know why
didn't open and the lines are very clear
but I've taught in India before and like
when I show them the video of a
self-driving car in California yeah I
mean that does seem like terrain that a
machine can navigate if you show them
the streets of like some of the places
in India I just don't even know what
kind of input do you just have to have a
very fast reactionary state of
processing so a complicated system but I
don't think that it's anything new I
don't think that like how societies
function up to now we've always had new
technologies like you know how do we
introduce the car how do we introduce
the printing press like all of these
things have required us to adjust the
way we understand and see the world
that's super insightful I have another
question you mentioned self-driving cars
and we started talking about robotics
but what about
rest of technologies such as like
education and medicine potentially what
impact would a I and Mo had on that yeah
so I think that that word impact is very
appropriate I was recently asked to be a
judge for the Google Isaiah impact
challenge where a lot of grant money was
awarded to 20 recipients and they all
came up with proposals on what kind of
impact a I could have social good impact
in the world and one of the things you'd
brought up right medical a lot of these
grants were awarded to medical use cases
looking at being able to parse through
medical records which is also evolved
right we have all this data how do we
use it how do we use it to do
preventative things how do we use it to
help not just humans but animals like
agriculture technology right a lot of
people in areas where they're focusing
on like food and plant livelihood are
able to now use technology to be able to
figure out how to best cultivate
resource for maximizing food and health
and safety and things like that you know
and the other thing is that now that we
have Android phones we have the ability
to do a lot of things with the camera
and we have on device we could build
models and train them on device we can
take this you know relatively
inexpensive medical device through the
phone and go to areas in the world where
you can diagnose infections and be able
to prescribe the right antibiotics or
medicines so these are things that you
would able to multiply the abilities of
these high-end demand skill sets like
medical but also other things like the
environment or agriculture or social
like services like education and the
ability to kind of have coverage in
areas that we didn't have before
so you mentioned the AI impact challenge
I happen to see I'm not sure which year
this challenge is going on but they
announced their winners at Google i/o
which was really awesome I think you
mentioned that you had something to do
it that you were a judge but I'm curious
like when you think about impact and AI
what about the ethical parts of AI and
Mo because like I would imagine that
some of these contestants or
participants in the challenge would have
to think about these things when they're
actually building out any of their you
know solutions to real-world problems so
I'm just curious what do you have to say
about using AI in a
ethically that was definitely one of the
considerations when reviewing and and
it's like often you get asked whether
you're speaking at a conference or at an
event that people will ask you know how
can I use AI we work with enterprise
customers a lot and they're using a idea
how better their business or to help
make better choices in directions that
they'd like to take so definitely AI is
a powerful tool to be used in these
processes when I was looking at these
applicants a lot of the stuff came to
mind I think especially when you're
dealing with something medically related
yeah it would be great to get kind of a
awesome medical data set but how do we
protect the people that are being you
know represented in this data and then
say you're using you know Google
assistant to check out how someone's
mental state of being is right how do
you make sure that that is not
infringing on that person's privacy so
these are things that really do need to
be not reactively thought about but
proactively thought about and so that's
something that you know I think it's
arguable that we're kind of keeping up
with the move of Technology but I also
feel like there's always more that can
be done in those regards so what kind of
tools are available to people who want
to start learning about AR start trying
to train models and what kinds of tools
do you work on that Google okay of
course there's buzz around a guy and
people are like oh I was just kind of
like the hype of the moment or something
but I think it's true that this
technology is gonna continue to improve
and it's gonna be a big part of society
and I think similar maybe not a exact
same way as how the printing press
changed spaceflights skill sets that
people needed I think you know if you
look at reading literacy 100 years ago
it was probably like you know 90% of the
world couldn't read and now it's like
flipped now it's like 90% of the world
can read so I think that if we could
stay on top of like what's going on in
the world and technology I think that's
very important so like for me personally
I try to read about what's going on what
other businesses are doing what other
research groups are working on you try
to keep track of the big conferences
Leichner ups and iclear and ICML I tweet
a lot just a lot of the current
interesting highlights of the moment in
machine learning and AI
but you know outside of just kind of
keeping up as to what is being presented
through conferences and media I think
you know a lot of really good resource
for learning the basics of it and just
understanding it from a technical
standpoint is the machine learning crash
course I've gone through it twice one
time I went through it like in like a
guided you know classroom and then I
kind of just went through it by myself
and just looked at every unit and work
through a lot of the basics and
fundamentals through that crash course
and it uses tensorflow Python so I'm
kind of have to have a baseline in that
but I thought it was one of the best
most you know up-to-date representation
of what AI is being most used right now
now there's other things like if you're
more interested in kind of exploring
open source projects there's like a
variety of open source machine learning
projects you know tensorflow is open
source project magenta which was the
team I was on it brain has a lot of
creativity based so music art generation
based models and so you could you know
provide your own data sets you can try
to build your own front-end for these
tools and yeah I think that would be
kind of in general type of tools that
you would use if you're not you're a
developer and you're just like you know
how can I use machine learning I think
the it's a matter of you know what
you're trying to do with it but there's
a whole range of types of tools let's
say so you could have pre trained models
so as you would you know get from
talking to Google assistant or Siri or
Alexa a lot of the speech-to-text is
ongoingly being worked on and so that
would be a use case that you wouldn't
need to build from scratch you could use
Google's pre-trained speech-to-text API
for example to be able to parse that or
things like natural language or things
that you know general image recognition
type use cases like maybe sentiments
like whether someone's happy or sad in a
photo those are things that are general
enough that can be continually worked on
by these bigger companies and if you
want something more custom so if you say
you have your own data you have like a
list of customers or you have a bunch of
retail data you want to be able to train
your own custom model that's where you
use auto machine learning which still
lets you cussed
a lot more than you would with some of
the pre-trained api's but at the same
time you're not really doing much of the
machine learning algorithms yourself
finally would be just you know you could
also always code it up from scratch so I
think that there's a whole range of
different tools that you can use to get
a better understanding of machine
learning and I do think that like as
we've seen as we've discussed and as
we've explaining with the AI impact
challenge I think having the right
problem also really matters if you're
getting serious into using machine
learning for real-world use cases so
Cheryl we'd like to do this thing on our
podcast where we axe our guests what is
something cooler awesome you've seen
done with AI r ml that you've seen done
recently so you want to share that with
us so yeah that's a really good question
I would definitely say one of the
biggest things to pay attention to is
Auto amount so for auto machine learning
it's really a step in between having the
API or having the model already pre
trained and ready to go you just give it
inputs and it gives you outputs it's
kind of the middle ground between that
and building everything from scratch and
so what you do with Auto machine
learning is it's the ability to be able
to take data that you have and create a
custom prediction model that suits your
needs specifically now I definitely
think as we talked about earlier with
ethics that it is in a sense
democratization and but I don't think it
replaces really understanding how
machine learning works so well I think
it's a great tool and it's gonna give a
lot of developers access to be able to
use machine learning in their
applications or tools that they want to
build I do think it's still important to
understand and how you would do it by
yourself if you needed to because as
much as we want it to be easy to use at
the end of the day some of it is still
being maintained you know by a third
party so I do think it's magical I think
it's great I think that there's a lot of
science behind that magic and it's great
to cultivate a curiosity to understand
how it all works but yeah I would say
that the coolest thing right now is this
ability to just see something like Auto
ml tables I worked on the promo video
for it and I showed some of my developer
friends after it was out and they were
just like on one hand it's like yeah of
course this should be a thing like of
course you should be able to just you
know select a column in your spreadsheet
and be able to
predictive values based off of the other
columns on the other hand it's like well
I can't believe this is like really
happening like we're actually at this
point where we can see this stuff so
yeah I think that that I mean there's so
many other things like going on right
now I think the AI impact challenge I
would check out the 20 projects that got
funded just to kind of see what the
latest and these are vetted by like you
know Jeff Dean and huge team of experts
as well so there's so much so thanks
Cheryl for joining us today and we're
running out of time but I wanted to know
if there is anything that we missed or
if you want to let our listeners know
where you're gonna be in the upcoming
months so yeah it was a great great
pleasure talking to you both I love
talking about artificial intelligence
it's a great passion of mine and I think
it's great to hear and discuss
technology and the potential for where
it's headed you know if you want to
follow me on Twitter you can find me at
FFP a la di n Twitter is FF paladin is
my twitter handle I also blog
occasionally on Eliza affect comm so you
could find me on that blog if you want
to check out that promo video for auto
amel tables that was a project that I
worked on as well so other than that
everything's basically on Twitter these
days so I would just use that yeah that
is done and it's your Twitter handle FF
paladin for final fantasy paladin
vengeance yeah I'm gonna date myself but
that was from the a.i.m days that was my
my aim name and I just kind of kept it
it became my Twitter handle and it's
been me ever since all right well that's
gonna do it for us today thank you for
joining us again Cheryl and we'll see
you on the next episode thanks Roger
awesome talking to Cheryl Cheryl has a
really big passion for ml and AI which
is something that we really really love
to see at Google yeah it's always great
when we get to talk to folks about AI
makes me happy talk about our question
of the week Asya
you mentioned that you can run App
Engine standard and rails so how do you
handle migrations so this is one of
those things that comes up every time we
deal with Ruby because ruby has a web
framework there's multiple but a lot of
folks these rails or use rails like
frameworks based on rack and we had to
handle this and we originally did App
Engine flex but you also run into
similar stuff with Django and someone on
our team has worked how to solve that
issue but the answer to how you run
migrations is with a gem we have called
the App Engine gem there'll be a link to
it in the show notes you install it like
any other gem and it basically gives you
the ability to run rake tasks rake for
those who aren't familiar with the Ruby
ecosystem is like me but for Ruby so it
starts with an R and this allows you to
run your arbitrary write commands things
like a rake DD migrate rate DB create
against your production environment and
it doesn't using cloud build and it's
really awesome because it lets you use
most of the same workflow that you're
used to but does things in a secure and
safe way and it's fantastic and it's
pretty seamless I've had a really really
good luck with it when I've been using
App Engine for applications in
production so that exists and that
answers a question probably the most
common question we get about rails plus
JCP is how do I handle migrations and
the answer is the App Engine gem and I
want to thank my colleague Daniel Zuma
for doing most of the development work
on that we wouldn't have it without his
passion for Ruby and rails so that is
our question of the week and my somewhat
wandering answer about it now for my
favorite part where's everyone going to
be John I hear you have some stuff
coming up want to tell us about that
yeah sure so I'll be flying to Seattle
maybe I get this stop by in the office
and hang out with you for a bit but I'll
be in Seattle for pax it should be
really fun pax from dev and pax Wes I'll
be talking at Pats dev with Mark Randall
and I'm real excited because we've been
working pretty hard on the demo for that
talk and it's gonna be really fun yay
one being keyword considering that this
is going to be a game demo games I'll
also be at the internal Google game
summit which is coming up in September
pretty excited about it because we get
to hang out with a bunch of people who
are really passionate about games and
seeing if we can really make this game
thing really happened at Google after
that I will be traveling to Canada to
hang out with my twin brother and
celebrates his marriage before it
happens this sounds interesting and
strategic and awesome are you gonna have
poutine get yourself some massively
awesome fries while you're in Canada
I've never had it but a lot of people
were telling me about the food and
Canada so I'm gonna check everything out
as much as possible because we have
quite that scenario I'm sure you dare
and Aza where are you gonna be I'm
boring I'm actually not boring I just
don't have a lot of travel planned right
now I'm focusing on spending some time
at home and getting stuff sorted at work
so the best place to catch me if you
want to see what I'm up to is catching
me on the Internet's if you happen to be
local here in Seattle I'm usually at
Seattle RB every Tuesday which is our
local Ruby Brigade Meetup and I will
probably be popping into various other
meetups over the next couple weeks and I
will be sure to tweet about that and if
you want to catch me on the Internet's
I am the underscore that emeasure on
Twitter and thank you my xur calm on the
Internet's is my blog so that's where
I'm gonna be sounds fun well I think
that's gonna wrap it up for this episode
and we would like to thank you all for
listening and we'd like to see you next
week see and Johnse Azure
[Music]
it's usually defined is used to indicate
in person
hey I need oh my gosh I don't know how
to shut that on the eyes interfering
with our energy right now
yeah the metal level of having a eye and
the fear with the oh yeah that's a great
tip it too right at the end of our
episode it's apparently giving a grammar
lesson today
I don't even know what did the advert
was usually defined as all right it's
been disabled